نار الحرب في اوكرانيا تستمر في التهام
الاخضر واليابس اصوات القصف تكاد لا تنقطع
بعد 16 شهرا من القتال ومع اشتداده في ظل
قيام كياف بهجوم مضاد واشنطن تحبس انفاسها
مع حلفائها الغربيين لقد انى الاوان لتحقق
اوكرانيا مكاسب دراماتيكيه على الارض بعد
استثمارات حربيه بعشرات المليارات
الوحدات الاوكرانيه تشن هجومها شرقي
البلاد لكن الامتداد الهائل للاراضي
المفخخه يعيق عمليه كياف الدبابات
الاوكرانيه تصطدم بكثافه الالغام المضاده
للدروع والافراد بحسب تقارير من ارض
المعركه لتجاوز ذلك تعتمد القوات
الاوكرانيه على اجهزه تقنيه خاصه تسمح
بازاله الالغام عن بعد ومركباتها المدرعه
ودباباتها مجهزه بما يكفي لتقويض حقول
الالغام هذه غير ان هذه القوات تواجه
تحديا يتمثل في العدد المحدود لهذه الالات
التي تتعرض لنيران المدفعيه الروسيه
ورغم تحقيقها مكاسب اضافيه تحتاج اوكرانيا
زياده في عدد الدبابات بالاضافه الى غطاء
بطائرات مقاتله لحمايه القوات البريه التي
تعمل على التقدم بحسب تحليل لصحيفه
بدات هجومها باستخدام الدبابات الغربيه
والعربات المدرعه التي تسلمتها حديثا
عمليه لاستعاده اكبر قدر ممكن من الاراضي
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا الاسبوع الاول من
الهجوم شهد تحقيق وحدات اوكرانيه مكاسب في
عده اقسام من الجبهه التي يبلغ طولها 600
ميل في جنوب وشرق البلاد المكاسب
الاوكرانيه شاقه غير ان مشكله روسيا
الكبرى تتمثل في انخفاض الروح المعنويه
لدى جنودها لمواجهه ذلك تعتمد موسكو على
القصف المكثف المواجهه مستمره ولا افق
قريب لكتابه نهايه الحرب
بلال البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات